all these years after its release
debates around Donnie Darko true meaning
rage on some elements can be adequately
explained while others are ambiguous and
ripe for interpretation we're here to
offer insight and lots of spoilers on
both fronts separating Donnie Darko
'he's deeper meaning from its surface
level narrative is crucial to
understanding the ending superficially
it's the story of wide-eyed teenager
Donnie portrayed by Jake Gyllenhaal
throughout the film he struggles to fit
in with his peers from the get-go Donnie
seems to suffer from delusions combined
with a track record of unruly behavior
regular therapy sessions and medication
it's heavily implied that Donnie is
suffering from paranoid schizophrenia
Donnie is experiencing what is commonly
called a daylight hallucination beyond
the typical challenges of adolescence
Donnie is plagued by disturbing
hallucinations of a six-foot tall rabbit
named Frank
he drinks rebels and falls in love with
one of his classmates Gretchen Ross
played by Jenna Malone he also has a
love/hate relationship with his parents
Rose and Eddie played by Mary McDonald
and Holmes Osborn and his sisters
Samantha and Elizabeth played by Dave a
chase and Jake Gyllenhaal's real-life
sister Maggie Gyllenhaal but Donnie
SaLuSa nations are part of a tangent
universe where doomsday is coming and
time-travel is real using this
outlandish premise director Richard
Kelly's cult classic simultaneously
tackles themes of fate religion
sacrifice love loss and loneliness let's
take a closer look at the philosophy of
time travel it's the book given to
Donnie by a science teacher Kenneth
monitor the book was written in 1944 by
wispy haired Roberta sparrow played by
actress patience Cleveland Sparrow used
to be a science teacher at Donny school
years before she was known as grandma
death the only way to make any sense of
the text is by reading excerpts directly
it's called the philosophy of time
travel music guess who wrote it
helpfully the 2003 director's cut DVD
included text from the fictitious book
the text provides a number of technical
terms relating to the two different
dimensions Donnie Darko takes place in
the primary universe and the tangent
universe the primary universe is the
universe we live in
the tangent universe is a carbon copy of
the primary universe which forms when
there's a glitch in the fourth dimension
of time excuse me
no duh is a product of fear in the
film's timeline this glitch occurs
shortly before the jet engine crashes
into the d'arco household on October 2nd
1988
that's when Donny first sees Frank in
his dreams after saving Donny's life by
guiding him away from his house Frank
makes a prophetic warning in 28 days six
hours 42 minutes and 12 seconds the
world will end here's the reason why
tangent universes are highly unstable
and only exists for a few weeks
eventually they collapse on themselves
according to the philosophy of time
travel they form a black hole within the
primary universe capable of destroying
all existence the events in the tangent
universe that occur from October 2nd to
October 31st transpire away from the
primary universes timeline in effect the
primary universe is on hold during the
tangent universe's existence which
explains the glitch in the fourth
dimension of time got all that
fortunately there's a way the universe
can be saved the artifact which in this
case is the jet engine is the key the
tangent universe is a like-for-like copy
of the primary universe the artifact is
an exception that materializes
spontaneously after a tangent universe
is formed this object made of metal is
erroneously copied twice and it's the
first sign that a tangent universe has
formed it's the only difference between
the two universes and it disrupts the
natural order of things
I'm not following you you see in order
for the tangent universe to collapse
safely after its 28-day lifespan it must
be identical to the primary universe so
the artifact needs to leave the tangent
universe before it can collapse the only
way to remove the artifact from the
universe is to send it through a time
portal back to the primary universe to
save the universe someone living inside
the tangent universe must transfer the
artifact back in time to October 2nd
1988 to clarify there are actually three
jet engines in donnie darko jet engine
one belongs in the primary universe
still attached to its airplane the
tangent universe forms containing jet
engine 2 and jet engine 3 jet engine 2
is correctly attached to the duplicated
airplane which Donnie's mother and
sister travel on later in the film jet
engine 3 is the anomaly with nowhere to
go in the tangent universe it crashes
into the dark au family's house but
Frank manages to save Donnie jet engine
2 is later torn from the airplane and
sent back to the primary universe
killing Donnie by the end of the film
the primary universe contains the
identical jet engine 1 and jet engine 2
but because the primary universe is
stable it's able to withstand the
anomaly of two identical objects Donnie
Darko is chosen as the living receiver
and his mission is to return the
artifact to the primary universe why was
Donnie chosen well as the philosophy of
time travel conveniently states no one
knows how or why a receiver will be
chosen you call this clarity the
philosophy of time travel states that
the living receiver is blessed with
fourth-dimensional powers including
quote enhanced strength telekinesis mind
control and the ability to conjure fire
in water knowing this helps explain how
Donnie was able to succeed in his
mission but these powers come with a
cost the living receiver also
experiences hallucinations and
terrifying dreams
who is he going to kill Donnie I can say
right now it's not only the living
receiver who's affected those who are
close to Donnie subconsciously guide him
along his mission often acting
erratically other than Donnie all of the
other characters fall into one of two
categories the manipulated living or the
manipulated dead
most characters in Donnie Darko fall
into the first category the manipulated
living they have an important job but
know little of it subconsciously helping
Donnie along his journey I guess some
people are just born with trench Dan
tartlet Donnie's fate is to kill Frank
portrayed by actor James Duval by
shooting him through the eye after Frank
is killed he becomes one of them
manipulated dead this is crucial without
Frank as a guide
Donnie would have no warning and no
indication of his role in saving the
universe anyone killed in the tangent
universe becomes one of the manipulated
dead they're in universe death makes
them more powerful than the manipulated
living this is presumably because their
spirits move beyond the material world
to a metaphysical dimension while they
remain alive in the suspended primary
universe they're capable of time travel
and unlike the living have conscious
knowledge of the threat of universal
annihilation
Frank's influence is obvious why do you
make me for the school
he commands Donny to flood the school
and burn down Jim Cunningham's house
every action that Frank encourages has
very significant consequences
Kenneth monotype helps Donny discover
his purpose by discussing wormholes
portals and the feasibility of time
travel before fellow teacher Karen
Pomeroy portrayed by Drew Barrymore
plays cupid between Gretchen and Donny
giving Gretchen this bizarre instruction
sit next to the boy you think is the
cutest quiet after she's fired she opts
for more overt tactics like writing
cellar-door on the chalkboard well after
leaving a Halloween party
Donny opens a cellar door shut at door
what but after opening the door he bumps
into bullies Seth and Ricky why are they
there because they are among the
manipulated living once they've dragged
Donny and Gretchen outdoors the pieces
are in place for Frank's arrival Frank
swerves his car to avoid Roberta sparrow
and ends up running over Gretchen the
events in the tangent universe imply
something or someone is orchestrating
everything behind the scenes graffiti
outside Donny school reads they made me
do it but who are they in the DVD
commentary director richard kelly
explains that the force in essence is
God throughout the film God is
represented in the form of a glowing
tunnel during therapy Donny refers to
the tunnels as workers assigned to each
one of us these workers first appear in
Donny's house leading Donny to his
parents room where he finds the gun he
eventually uses to kill Frank during
therapy Donny opens up about his fear of
dying alone without discovering God it
sounds highly unlikely he would have
ever sacrificed himself the search for
God is absurd it is if everyone dies
alone however Donny's direct
communication with God in the form of
the aforementioned workers comforts him
Donny utters a phrase - Seth when
Frank's speeding car saves him from the
knife wielding bully
what a deus ex machina is in reference
to a plot device used in fiction when an
unexpected event saves a hopeless
situation however its translation god
from the machine has a different
implication Donnie knows Frank's arrival
is part of God's plan as they take a
stroll through the park
Gretchen asked Donnie and what if you
could go back in time and take all those
hours of pain and darkness and replace
them with something better
that comment seems innocent at the time
but remember Gretchen is one of them
manipulated dead since she dies in the
tangent universe she was nudging Donnie
toward his fate and what if you could go
back in time and take all those hours of
pain and darkness or replace them with
something better after shooting Frank
Donnie carries Gretchen's body to his
house stops off to kiss a sleeping
Elizabeth on the head then drives the
family car to carpathian Ridge an
ominous twister like cloud forms but
what happens next as the plane his
mother and sister have both boarded
travels towards the cloud Donnie
chuckles on first viewing it's unclear
that he's using telekinesis a power
given to him as the living receiver to
rip the engine from the plane and send
it through the portal back in time to
the primary universe the natural order
of the universe is thus restored which
means the tangent universe can collapse
safely as Frank's countdown reaches zero
the collapse is symbolized by the past
28 days played in Reverse Donnie's voice
over reads aloud from the letter he sent
to Roberta sparrow I hope that when the
world comes to an end I can breathe a
sigh of relief because there will be so
much to look forward to the narrative
then returns to the primary universe
last seen at the beginning of the film
before Donnie's woken up by Frank
Donnie sits up in bed hysterically
laughing then jet engine 2 sent back in
time from October 30th crashes into his
room and Donnie's killed Donnie Darko
how kind of name is bad it's like some
sort of superhero or something
what makes you think I'm not in the end
Donnie Darko is a superhero story when
he wakes up in bed after successfully
returning the artifact Donnie laughs
because he saved the universe and saved
the lives of Gretchen and Frank his
impact reaches further into the primary
universe - with the characters later
recollecting key moments from the
tangent universe in the philosophy of
time and travel it's said that when the
manipulated living and dead wake up in
the primary universe they are often
haunted by the experience in their
dreams in other words they experience a
vague recollection of events living on
in their subconscious in one of the most
fitting choices for the movie's
soundtrack an acoustic cover of Tears
for Fears mad world plays which notably
includes the line the dreams in which
I'm dying are the best I've ever had
it's an apt reference to Donnie Darko
the troubled teen who sacrificed his
life to protect the universe and whose
heroism is only vaguely remembered in
the dreams of all the people he saved
tune in next time when looper weighs in
on the many merits of performance art
troupe Sparkle motion sometimes I doubt
your commitment to spark emotion check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]